je suis à la grande école maintenant
c'est la rentrée et jean a plein de
nouveaux quotas alors ils aimeraient en
parler à sa maman mais ça fait si
longtemps qu'il n'a pas vu sinon je
sache écrire comme ça je crois que ma
maman terme allemand bah oui j'en ai
elle est jolie maman c'est pas mon nom
c'est ma nounou mais un jour je reprends
une nouvelle incroyable ah ouais j'ai
aussi une carte postale pour toi
c'est un moment qu'il a été mon cher
jean mon petit chéri je suis malheureux
mon charge je suis en afrique je skie
sur les mains vides et qu il
jaro avec deux scènes non vol
art
allez je vous jure de chocolat glacé
comme il est une pluie
tout
artix un costume d'avion j'en ai pas au
bout de ses surprises
et l'évidence qui se trouvera pour le
changer pour toujours
ma maman est en amérique elle a
rencontré buffalo bills prochainement
sur inferno j'étais proche donné